we previously had a segment called the
road to Enlightenment and that was me uh
kind of sharing my experience as I was
getting into Buddhism and mindfulness
and meditation the only issue is that it
was a fatally flawed segment didn't last
very long and was promptly canceled uh
the reason being uh as I got deeper into
it I realized it's going to take me some
time to really get the hang of this and
develop anything that would be
reminiscent of not even expertise but
just proficiency right and so I was like
well it's not going to be fun or an
entertaining or informative for me to
just come in every week and say hey I
meditated a few times this past week
seemed to be fine well and if the
segment went too well eventually you'd
find yourself backed into a corner where
you basically had to flex about how
enlightened you were getting yeah which
seems like it would defeat the point
yeah I mean there's a lot of ways it
could have gone but literally none of
them were good yeah right but the good
thing is we saw that but before it went
any of those directions and promptly
canceled it but I knew that eventually
I'd want to return with a more
substantive segment or multiple segments
over you know over the years about
mindfulness and meditation uh basically
when I have something useful to say now
uh in recent months a month or two ago I
did a I wrote an article in the mass
research review about mindfulness and a
few key applications that might be of
interest to Fitness enthusiasts so I
wanted to share a little glimpse into
not my personal experience necessarily
with mindfulness and meditation but I
wanted to to actually take a look at
some of the research that's out there
and uh I know what you're thinking how
much research could they there possibly
be you know it seems like there's a lot
of anecdote about this but you might not
have heard too much about you know
actual scientific research I'll be
honest I knew that it was studied in
some areas you know different type types
of mindfulness-based interventions and
meditation interventions I fully and
grossly underestimated the sheer
quantity of research pertaining to
mindfulness so I found a systematic
review by Goldberg and colleagues
and in the systematic review they found
44 separate
meta-analyzes about mindfulness-based
interventions now that's not 44 separate
studies that's 44 separate meta-analyzes
within that there were 336 randomized
controlled trials with a total
participant pool of over 30 000
participants so like you know we're out
here talking about betaine and you can
find like six relevant studies meanwhile
mindfulness out here you know thirty
thousand participants cumulative so
there is a really considerable amount of
mindfulness and meditation related
research that is spread across many
different fields investigating many
different clinical outcomes of Interest
so
um what I want to focus on in this
segment is just a few key areas that
Fitness folks might be interested in
specifically training performance sleep
pain management and eating behaviors so
before we get into the Super applied
stuff for dig in into specific studies I
want to cover the basics and and of
course I want to address a caveat that
still exists I'm still a novice in the
area of studying mindfulness meditation
and Buddhism I no longer claim to be I
no longer put the big secular Buddhism
tag on it uh I I started going to asanga
locally so every week I have a
meditation group where we study Buddhism
and we meditate together so I do
consider myself to be a practicing
Buddhist uh in the Vietnamese Zen
Buddhism tradition and uh you know I
used to always put the secular tag on it
but the deeper I get into this
particular lineage of Buddhism I just
haven't found anything that strains uh
my beliefs or like brings me into a
metaphysical realm where I'm just like
ah doesn't really make sense so well is
that because the particular School of
Buddhism you subscribe to is inherently
secular it is it is a pretty secular
interpretation of it yeah and but you
know I've talked to a lot of folks and
from what I gather again novice not an
expert someone's going to come dunk on
me on the internet I'm sorry from what I
can gather from a lot of different uh
Zen lineages that I've seen it seems
like they do tend to be pretty secular
by default it's not like they're taking
it and saying well let's you know
repackage this and make it more secular
that just seems to be kind of the the
common approach in a lot of different uh
traditions and lineages of Zen Buddhism
is that uh you know there's uh there's
just not a big focus on the elements of
what we might consider religious in
nature so not a lot of metaphysical
stuff not a lot of dogmatic stuff not a
lot of uh attachment to various rituals
and stuff so yeah it does you know from
from a western perspective you know
growing up it from my perspective it
does seem to be a lot more secular in
nature than I had anticipated or
expected
um but yeah so so I I'm
currently uh you know practicing in the
kind of Vietnamese Zen Buddhism
tradition and really enjoying it but the
big caveat here is you know I'm still a
novice I'll know way more about this
stuff in six months and I'll know way
more about it in six years so I'm just
kind of presenting the evidence here uh
to the best of my ability but first I
want to start out with uh
yeah you're highlighting the quote that
I have there I'm just curious who that
quotes from hell it was rumset so the
the smart-ass quote that I put in the
outline and almost skipped but now I
have to say talking about how I don't
have all the knowledge I'd like to have
and in many years I'll know a lot more
about this stuff than I do now the quote
was you go you go to war with the Army
you have not the Army you might want or
wish you had at a later time and that is
Donald Rumsfeld who has never been
convicted of a war crime uh
yeah we should we should move on before
I get myself in trouble okay so I want
to start with some definitions right so
number one quick description of
mindfulness because a lot of people when
they hear about it it is a term where
they say but what does that mean
mindfulness of of what right because a
lot of times in just common speech we'll
say hey make sure you're you're mindful
of blank so uh a really good basic
definition that goes around a lot
mindfulness is awareness that arises
through paying attention on purpose in
the present moment and non-judgmentally
so a lot of different mindfulness-based
practices involve basically bringing
your attention to the present moment
very intentionally and just kind of
observing your experience without
passing judgment uh just kind of calmly
observing and I I mentioned a lot of
times people say mindfulness of what and
that's a very good question and uh
tiknot Han is a a zen master uh a monk
in the Vietnamese then Buddhist
tradition uh tiknot Han often says
mindfulness is always mindfulness of
something so you might be sitting and
doing a mindfulness exercise and you
might be mindful of your breath focusing
on your breath that's a very common
thing in various types of meditation uh
you might be mindful of what you're
eating right so mindful eating is a
common uh intervention that we see in
the nutrition literature and that's
exactly what it's sounds like it's
taking time to be present during that
meal and really immersing yourself in
that that meal experience and bringing
all of your focus and attention to it
um and so yeah you could be mindfulness
of a lot of different things uh
sometimes they'll they'll do what you
call a body scan meditation where you
lay down and you work through you know
from your feet to your head or vice
versa
and you're just focusing very intently
on my feet what am I what Sensations am
I feeling in my feet currently and you
think about relaxing the muscles in your
feet you work up to your your calves
your thighs you know you kind of work
all the way up and you're being mindful
of a particular part of your body just
observing your Sensations not judging
them you know not trying to force them
to be any specific way it's just simply
paying attention and a lot of times when
you are able to achieve some sense of
mindfulness and you're doing it
intentionally it can bring a sense of
calmness and Clarity and stability to
one's mind uh which brings me to
meditation uh so TIG not Han often says
that meditation has two components
stopping and looking deeply but but
ultimately it depends on the type of
meditation that you're doing so uh
meditation takes a lot of different
forms it is probably the most common
mindfulness based intervention of many
uh you know so for example some people
consider different types of yo yoga to
be a mindfulness-based Intervention when
done a certain way but but I saw a link
a really nice link from headspace which
is an app I don't know a lot about the
app but they talk about different types
of meditation and so for example there's
guided versus unguided meditation
there's calming versus Insight
Meditation so a lot of times people
think meditation necessarily implies
that you are really focused on
contemplating about some major topic and
you're trying to you know have some kind
of epiphany sometimes there are
meditation practices that are simply
there for calming you know just to kind
of let your mind rest and to calm down
and relax
sometimes you do Insight met focused
meditations where you actually will calm
your mind first just to make sure that
you have you know appropriate levels of
focus and concentration uh and kind of
just bring that stability to your mind
and then you might start to contemplate
on you know something that you would
kind of plan to think about and get some
insight on beforehand so there might be
something big in your life or a big
topic that you want to really think
about and and contemplate about and get
some insight so there are different ways
to do meditation uh some someone's that
come to mind like I said body scan
different types of visualization
um you know reflection uh sometimes
people chant mantras sometimes people do
yoga there are a ton of different types
of meditation but generally many of them
involve calming your mind and then
bringing your attention bringing
mindfulness to some object of meditation
whether it's just calming your mind
focusing on your breath death focusing
on the sound of a bell or some kind of
calm music there's a lot of different
ways to do it so with that out of the
way the question is what can
mindfulness-based practices or
interventions actually do for fitness
enthusiasts and I'm going to talk about
a few different areas of research and in
the interest of time I'm going to kind
of go pretty superficial high level with
them rather than getting really into
details but I will put a lot of
references to mostly systematic reviews
and meta-analyzes so people can dig a
little bit deeper if they wish to but
the reason this topic came up in Mass
was because there was a new study a new
systematic review on mindfulness and
mental fatigue
now I wanted to cover this because
mindfulness uh you know certainly
interests me uh but also because uh Mike
zordos Dr zordos has written a few
articles over the last few years about
mental fatigue and uh Research indicates
that when people are mentally kind of
acutely fatigued going into a workout it
can negatively affect their resistance
training performance and so what that
means is you know in a laboratory
setting for example they might bring
people in and say hey do these kind of
kind of tricky math problems but do them
quickly and understand that you have to
get them right you know they put a time
pressure they put an accuracy pressure
it's cognitively demanding and they say
do all these math problems as fast as
you can go and when people do that they
get mentally fatigued and that type of
mentally draining exercise when done
with enough volume essentially can carry
over into a training session and
interfere with your performance even
something as simple as looking at a
smartphone between sets I think in in
one of the in one of the studies there
was just enough going on in the phone uh
that that it was enough to kind of
derail people and cause some degree of
acute mental fatigue yeah like like
before the testing session I think like
one group just sat quietly for 30
minutes and then the other group just
like scrolled social media for 30
minutes and uh yeah people scrolling
social media were fatigued yeah and so
yeah that wasn't between sets but that
is something that came up in the
interpretation it's like it's one of the
most common things to do between sets
these days is kind of pop open your
phone and mess around and and yeah could
potentially contribute to some some
acute mental fatigue
um you know other things that they'll do
sometimes in lab settings is like memory
tasks and again the whole idea is to get
your mind uh really riled up get you
thinking about things that are
cognitively demanding and often putting
some kind of pressure with regards to
time or accuracy or just adding
complexity putting a bunch of
information in your head and saying hey
you need to retain this stuff
um so mental fatigue not a good thing
for acute performance and what they're
looking at uh this was a systematic
review by cow and colleagues CAO
probably pronouncing that wrong uh but
they were looking at studies using
mindfulness-based interventions to try
to
facilitate recovery from acute mental
fatigue uh so they were looking at
intervention a variety of different
mindfulness-based interventions uh
comparing it to uh you know you know
some kind of non-mindfulness-based
intervention with some possibility of
inducing acute mental fatigue and
basically figuring trying to figure out
does this mindfulness type exercise
um facilitate you know recovery from
this acute mental fatigue not going to
bore people with the details but I will
pop a couple things up on the screen
here so right now you can look at table
two if you're watching on YouTube just
kind of an overview of the different uh
interventions that were used to induce
mental fatigue in the eight studies that
qualified for this systematic review uh
now and you can of course pause that if
you want to dig into the details I'll
put the the high res stuff up on the
screen and now looking at table three
it's just an overview of the different
mindfulness-based interventions and that
sounds like a vague term but they wanted
to cast a broad enough net so we're
talking about meditation audio
instruction that kind of walks you you
through a mindfulness exercise you know
a lot of stuff like you know guided
meditation things like that those are
the types of interventions going on here
and generally speaking they were pretty
short in duration you know a lot of them
were only 5 10 15 minutes or so
um and results painting with a very
broad brush here given a basic overview
results were generally pretty favorable
indicating that some of these
mindfulness-based interventions did
facilitate recovery from mental fatigue
and in some cases led to improvements in
psychological and physical performance
outcomes and I think you know you if
you're interested in digging deeper of
course there's the mass article there is
the the full text of this article
um you know there are some caveats you
know the benefits likely will depend on
sufficient experience uh intervention
quality duration of intervention and
there can be a lot of variation from
person to person so I don't want to make
it seem like all mindfulness-based
interventions are equivalent in terms of
Effectiveness nor do I want to make it
seem like it's the perfect intervention
for everybody but broadly speaking the
results were pretty favorable and I
think that this does have plenty of face
validity you know so if we look at acute
mental fatigue and say what is the
problem here and a lot of times it's
we're asking our mind to do a lot of
pretty heavy lifting cognitively or
doing some multitasking trying to rush
through things do some cognitive
challenges and kind of keep a lot of
different plates spinning at once yeah
like if you're if you're going to the
gym after work and like you gotta drive
through rush hour traffic and like you
know people honking there's like
accidents on the side of the road like
you it takes a lot of mental effort to
stay to stay like totally engaged and
just get to the gym uh safely and so
like it it might make sense to just kind
of like take a second and and take a
quick breather in the parking lot before
you go in yeah and that's what's really
encouraging about the the specific
interventions is that many of them were
only 10 or 15 minutes long and we
probably do like I would imagine uh I
don't we have weird jobs I I don't know
how much we can generalize our
experience to others but like when I
finish work for the day there's usually
a big push to the finish line and almost
always I have like a minute where I'm
like I need to kind of recover like I
just did some mentally challenging stuff
uh I think a lot of people after leaving
from a full work day making the commute
over to the gym uh or chasing the kids
around the house and then you finally
get a moment where you can get out to
the gym uh it's very common to enter the
gym in a mentally fatigued State
um and so for a lot of folks I think
there's a lot of face validity here if
we think about the things that are used
to experimentally induce mental fatigue
you can kind of think well what would be
the opposite of that and it's like okay
focus on a single thing calmly relax
focus on your breathing as you focus on
one thing this is a lot of times people
wonder what is the purpose like you tell
someone on the surface focus on your
breathing it'll make you perform better
and it's like what the hell do you mean
how can that possibly be the case but
what we're talking about here is having
a single-minded focus on something
that's not cognitively demanding or
challenging there's no accuracy pressure
time pressure it's basically giving your
brain a bit of a rest with a calming
exercise and saying by focusing on one
thing the breath which is very easy or
whatever the you know the instruction
video or audio is telling you to focus
on by focusing on one thing with all of
our attention we fight our urge to focus
on 700 things with really fragment
attention and we're thinking about what
we did two hours ago at work and what we
have to do tonight when we get home uh
it can be a surprisingly restorative and
restful thing
um now moving on I'm going to hit some
highlights here very briefly uh
mindfulness and sleep
let me just say this anecdotes are
obviously the top form of evidence
I passed out listening to a guided
meditation last night and I slept like a
baby it was incredible
um so sleep research it's hard to do but
generally the consensus is if you're
into fitness sleep probably ought to be
important to you uh you know sleep
restriction especially chronically is
pretty bad for performance seems to be
pretty bad for training adaptations as
well with the limited evidence that we
have
the challenge with sleep though is that
we don't have a lot of control over the
amount that we sleep like you cannot
consciously just say tonight I will get
nine hours of excellent sleep you don't
get to do that yeah all you can really
do is give yourself sleep opportunities
uh and couple that with sleep hygiene
right so what you can say is
because I've been sleeping like [ __ ] I'm
going to spend eight hours in bed
tonight and in the hours leading up to
bed I'm gonna try to practice good sleep
hygiene and do everything I can
behaviorally to set myself up for a high
likelihood of getting high quality sleep
tonight and the reason I bring that up
is because
if you look at the lists of sleep
hygiene guidelines in a variety of
different you know reputable resources
you know foundations that really focus
on sleep research or you know practical
interventions to facilitate people with
Sleep Disorders or sleep issues
um you know when you go to any of these
big organizations or research groups
that have sleep hygiene guidelines
it basically it's going to come in one
of two forms one of them is going to
describe meditation without calling it
meditation they're going to say like hey
you know maybe dim the lights and lay
down or sit down and relax and you know
just try to you know calm yourself and
maybe listen to a guided relaxation uh
thing and they're just calling they're
just saying meditation without calling
it that yeah but most sleep hygiene
guidelines will sleep hygiene guidelines
will just say hey do a meditation
exercise before bed like it's a good way
to kind of calm down wind down and get
yourself in a place where you're really
relaxed and able to sleep really well uh
and I have you ever tried this by the
way yeah so I I was actually about to
cut you off and and interject uh a bit
of advice I was going to give is try to
find a version of of like meditating or
mindfulness practice that that clicks
for you
um so I used to have like my my sleep
these days is great and I'm I'm very uh
grateful about that but back in the day
I used to have some pretty major sleep
issues uh like like borderline insomnia
pretty frequently I just lay in bed
couldn't get my mind to stop racing just
couldn't fall asleep uh when I was in
college
a hypnotist came to the school uh and
and did like a little like hypnotism
show in the auditorium
um I still don't know the extent to
which those are like real or fake like
whether the students that they call up
or like Patsy's I don't know there's a
part of me that wants to believe but
then there's a part of me that's just
like if I was on that stage I don't
think I do half the ridiculous [ __ ] that
these people do so who knows I'd
whatever but uh anyway uh on the way out
the door he mentioned like hey oh hey in
the lobby like I'll have a little table
set up
um and if you would like to buy like a
guided meditation uh CDs uh you can you
can do that and since I was having sleep
issues like one of them was for sleep
and I was like okay like I'll give this
a shot this sounds awesome uh so I
bought the CD and I tried to listen to
it the first night
and uh got one of the worst experiences
of my life uh because so I'm I'm very
much like a a princess in the P type
individual when it comes to sleeping
like if it's dark and cool and
completely silent or just like white
noise whatever I can sleep just fine but
if there's any like spoken word any sort
of like music anything like that I just
I just can't fall asleep and it just
annoys the [ __ ] out of me so like I had
this CD on and I was thinking like oh
well like maybe this is something
different and it gets like 10 minutes in
and like I was just getting [ __ ]
pissed off it's just like there's some
annoying person in the corner of your
room just talking their mouth off yeah
like would you shut up yeah I was like
I'm trying to sleep shut the [ __ ] up
stop it and like I was getting like
legitimately heated I was like okay
maybe this isn't for me yeah um but yeah
so so to fall asleep now I do my own
silent like uh uh meditation practice
which which is usually like it's it's
not the kind of like meme version of
just like counting sheep but just like
some repetitive task that I find
enjoyable I'll just like imagine myself
doing that yeah
um it's typically shooting free throws
like yeah uh someone is passing the ball
back to me shoot a free throw get a ball
shoot a free throw never taking my my
mind's eye off of the rim uh and that
usually puts me right out yeah and
that's a great example I mean that's
mindfulness of free throw visually
visualization right but it's something
that is repetitive not cognitively
demanding not something that's going to
light up all your neurons you know you
want to be looking at an fmri and be
like whoa there's a bunch of fireworks
in the brain right I mean it's it's just
calming repetitive simple stuff that
isn't uh you know cognitively
challenging in any way uh and that
that's what you get with a lot of these
kind of sleep-oriented guided
mindfulness or meditation exercises is
you know focus on your breath do a body
scan bring your mind to something that's
very simple something that's in the
present moment very very straightforward
um so yeah um obviously you know we
don't just want to say oh hey this sleep
Foundation says it's good that's science
enough for me or you know hey here's an
anecdote I like doing this it's fine
um I will put in the show notes uh two
different meta-analyzes indicating that
uh mindfulness meditation can have
positive effects on sleep parameters
both in patients with insomnia but also
uh in more of just the general
population one was more from like
workplace mindfulness trainings in
people who were not uh who did not have
any kind of clinical sleep disruption uh
so a couple meta meta-analyzes pointing
in the right direction and the workplace
one um
you know it did improve their sleep but
there's also improvements in uh assessed
mindfulness which isn't surprising uh
but but there are improvements in stress
anxiety psychological distress and just
overall well-being so a lot of things
that you kind of see these things go
together you know calming your mind a
few times throughout the day can kind of
help you get re-centered and kind of
recapture some of that mental and
emotional stability throughout the day
and then when you're sleeping better
it's a lot easier to manage stress well
manage anxiety well uh and ultimately
feel like you have a lot better
well-being throughout the day I mean I
know for me personally sleep disruption
immediately you know my anxiety is worse
my ability to cope with strong emotions
throughout the day is worse you know it
it really sets me up for a pretty tough
time if I'm not sleeping well uh moving
on uh mindfulness for pain management
this is one of the areas of mindfulness
research that's pretty active and
there's some pretty solid data in this
area I don't want to belabor the point
too much because we've talked about it
on the show before and on other people's
shows but this the bio psychosocial
model of pain you know back in the day
pain the world was simpler right you
have a a little tiny pain receptor and
it's angry and therefore you have pain
and that's the end of it uh good old
Cartesian dualism yeah that's not really
how we do it anymore biopsychosocial
model of pain is picked up a lot in the
in the the pain research and that's kind
of found its way into the fitness world
uh you know the folks over at barbell
medicine have done a lot of the work of
kind of popularizing those ideas and
it's for the better you know it's good
that we have a more nuanced
understanding of pain within the Fitness
World
um now one of the things that I find
really interesting is that uh you know
if you look at some of the peer-reviewed
papers on the biopsychosocial model of
pain many of these papers will posit
that there are four key elements to
consider with a pain experience there's
no susception there's pain there's pain
behaviors and there is suffering so they
actually explain suffering as being
basically a type of emotional response
to perceived pain and they identify that
as a specific kind of independent
component of the pain experience they
also talk about pain behaviors which is
essentially actions that people carry
out in response to perceived pain and
these are things that are influenced by
both subconscious elements but also just
conditioned responses so to some extent
we we are kind of experiencing these
conditioned responses that have kind of
been planted in our minds a little bit
so in the Fitness World now when people
talk about the biopsychosocial model of
pain and how we attract how we approach
pain among lifters people talk a lot
about pain narratives and usually people
are talking that talking about that in
terms of how you discuss pain with a
client or how a person would discuss
pain with their health practitioner so
we talk about setting these pain
narratives of just how pain is framed
because we don't want to plant these
seeds where we are conditioning
responses that exaggerate the pain or
amplify the pain we want to make sure
that we are being really mindful of
these subjective elements of the pain
experience that that can absolutely be
influenced by the way we speak about it
the way we frame it and that emotional
element that suffering element and I
couldn't get over the fact that you know
by explicitly making suffering its own
element uh it's it's kind of no surprise
that mindfulness meditation being
derived from Buddhism has a pretty clear
application there you know the four
noble truths uh often viewed as kind of
the the foundational teaching in
Buddhism uh traditionally it's framed as
being Buddha's uh first teaching after
achieving Enlightenment but it's about
the truth of suffering the cause of
suffering the end of suffering and the
path that frees us from suffering right
so suffering kind of a big deal in what
in Buddha Buddhism which is where we get
mindfulness meditation practices from uh
so I I think there's obviously a pretty
clear uh link there or a clear parallel
where you'd say Okay aside from just
how we speak about injury with a coach
or with a medical professional we could
also think about you know how might
mindfulness meditation allow us to kind
of explore some of these elements of
pain and you know no one is going to go
out there and say hey Pain's all in your
head and if you just become calm enough
it'll go away right well some people do
well they shouldn't I mean the the folks
who uh
learned about the biopsychosocial model
like two weeks ago yeah I think some I
think some of the what's the what's that
saying like no one has more Zeal than a
new convert yeah I I think
I think some folks take it a little bit
too far but yeah like like real
practitioners tend to not do that yeah
yeah so you know I think of course there
are you know when it comes to how we
actually act upon this biopsychosocial
model like I said a lot of it has to do
with how we speak about pain how we
interact with coaches and health
practitioners when we're talking about
pain but also
um you know there is an element here
where we want to dig into these other
elements of pain right so so not just
the you know the no susceptive kind of
biological root of pain but also looking
at the emotional element that we would
call suffering in this case
um looking at some of those conditioned
elements and mindfulness meditation
generally speaking if you were to boil
it down it involves you know basically
calming your mind uh decentering
yourself a little bit and taking an
objective look at the situation whatever
you happen to be contemplating about and
separating you know some of the uh
perceived elements from the the the true
stuff right so kind of figuring out how
much is my perception distorting the way
I see this experience or feel this
experience and so uh you know I think
there's definitely a clear Avenue where
you would say that mindfulness
meditation exercises might have a
valuable role here where you know the
the object of the mindfulness-based
intervention would be your pain and you
would start to say okay this pain is
real I'm experiencing it but is it
possible that there are some emotional
elements that are kind of amplifying the
pain that I'm feeling is it possible
that fear about the pain is amplifying
the just general dread and anxiety
associated with this pain experience you
can start to unravel uh you know the
kind of biological root of the pain from
some of the emotional elements and
psychological elements and conditioned
elements that are really distorting your
pain experience and in most cases
amplifying it and making it turn into
something that causes a lot of anxiety
and fear that is related to the pain but
not necessarily linked to the pain
directly you know you can separate those
out and a mindfulness type of of
intervention might allow you to address
some of those psychological and
emotional elements and basically remove
some of their power a little bit and
yeah the biological elements will will
persist but it might have a big impact
on the subjective pain experience and
without digging into to you know a ton
of different studies on it what I'll
probably do is just link
some meta-analyzes in the show notes
like I said this literature is
developing pretty substantially here
it's not like one or two little pilot
studies there are some meta-analyzes
that I can absolutely uh Link in the
show notes here but broadly speaking it
does look like a lot of these
mindfulness mindfulness based
interventions are pretty helpful in
reducing self-reported pain levels uh
you know in clinical populations who
have chronic pain so there's
meta-analyzes by Goldberg and colleagues
and by Hilton and colleagues where
they've shown that some of these mindful
mindfulness-based interventions are
effective
um not it's not like it's a magic thing
that's going to immediately turn the
pain off but it can alleviate some of
those subjective pain symptoms uh now
the final thing I want to mention here
uh very briefly mindful eating we've
talked about it on the podcast before so
I'm not going to belabor the point but I
did want to make people aware of a good
resource there's a paper by uh the it
was a single author paper by Nelson and
it provides the best description I've
seen in the peer-reviewed literature
about how you actually do mindful eating
you know because some people are like
okay so what just eat a meal and pay
attention uh it goes a little deeper
than that but that is kind of broadly
what it is right but it's about really
taking your time with the meal
um savoring the meal uh enjoying the
meal and focusing on the food not in a
way that connotes any type of guilt uh
you know not a deviation from Fitness
driving but it's about really enjoying
the meal and enjoying the food for what
it is and and enjoying the fact that you
are having a pleasant eating experience
nourishing your body giving it the the
nutrients it needs so there's a great uh
paper like I said by Nelson LinkedIn the
show notes that actually talks you
through what it would look like to try
mindful eating
um a lot of people say okay well does it
work and that really comes down to what
you think it's supposed to do so some
people wonder often if mindful eating
induces weight loss
and the evidence there is mixed
um so I'll link a couple uh
meta-analyzes and systematic reviews
again in the show notes uh generally
speaking like I said there's some
evidence indicating some interventions
where mindful mindful eating does
indirectly almost kind of
unintentionally lead to some weight loss
but it's very mixed some studies show no
real impact on weight loss but most
importantly that's really not the goal
you know you don't do a mindful eating
in for a mindful eating intervention and
say all right hopefully everybody loses
20 pounds here that's really not the
point and if weight loss occurs and
sometimes it does it's usually kind of a
side effect it's an indirect thing that
that happens rather than the explicit
outcome that has been sought or that the
major outcome of interest but when we
look at other outcomes so for example
caterman and colleagues uh looked at
mindful uh mindful eating interventions
and they found that it led to reductions
in binge eating and emotional eating and
populations who were engaging in those
behaviors there was another systematic
review by you and colleagues where they
found that mindful eating was associated
with reductions in emotional eating
external eating binge eating weight and
shape concern and there were also
improvements related to self-acceptance
and emotional regulation Again
meta-analysis by Rogers and colleagues
finding a whole bunch of favorable
changes related to eating behaviors
depression anxiety eating attitudes so
generally speaking we see that mindful
eating interventions have a lot of
positive outcomes associated with them
in you know meta-analyzes and systematic
reviews but it's simply not explicitly a
weight loss intervention so
um the the utility there is more on the
psychological and behavioral side of
eating uh and just trying to sort out so
you know sometimes people have some like
borderline pathology eating attitudes
and mindful eating interventions seem to
be quite helpful with alleviating some
of those symptoms
now I want to get into some caveats here
um the very first thing I want to
mention as a caveat is I've talked about
some clinical outcomes here and studies
that have been done in clinical patients
whatever your interest is if you believe
that you have a clinical condition that
may warrant medical intervention or
advice from a medical professional don't
don't avoid seeking that medical care
because you're going to try to do
mindfulness stuff instead this stuff is
not meant to replace modern medicine or
anything like that
um you know if you think you need some
medical attention or if you're on the
fence and you're not sure the best case
scenario is go see a medical
professional who's qualified they'll let
you know what you need and if you see
them and they say you know what you can
you can talk to them about it and say I
was thinking about maybe doing some
mindfulness-based interventions to try
to do this without getting into a really
intense kind of medical intervention and
maybe they'll be supportive of that but
don't use this stuff as a reason to
delay medical care that might very well
be necessary another caveat is obviously
unbiased like I said I consider myself
to be a practicing Buddhist very early
in that process but uh there's no
question that I have bias here which is
frankly why I tried to make sure I was
citing a lot of systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes because of course yeah
anyone with a bias can go say oh look at
this pilot study in nine people looks
pretty good so I wanted to to rely on
papers that utilize systematic
literature searches rather than just
kind of picking you know cherry picking
this study or that study
um now there are some nerds who are
skeptical of the mindfulness literature
and I do think it's important to
highlight that so
um I say nerds in an endearing way
um there there's something called the
framework for open and reproducible uh
research training and they maintain a
running list of psychological
replications and reversals you know it's
basically
uh basically a result of the fact that a
whole bunch of foundational psychology
findings turned out to be unreliable and
could not be replicated or reproduced
and so people have said we need
basically like a database to figure out
of all the pillars of knowledge in our
field which of them actually support
load you know and which ones are just
like Styrofoam pillars that don't
actually do anything yeah
um now on this web page
um they do include uh mindfulness for
mental health uh and and they say most
studies are low quality and use
inconsistent designs there's higher
heterogeneity than other mental health
treatments and their strong reason to
suspect reporting bias now to be clear
there are other elements on this webpage
where there are
aggressive and just really obvious
debunking of some of these theories
that's not the case with mindfulness
here and and it is specific to mental
health not all mindfulness outcomes
um basically it's on their list of like
hey there's a reason to be cautious here
like let's keep an eye on this yeah um
so it hasn't been like soundly debunked
but there there are credible concerns
about how reliable you know I mentioned
there's a lot of randomized controlled
trials people are saying you know what I
appreciate that there's a lot of rcts
here but I wish that they were generally
designed better and and we suspect that
maybe there's some reporting bias that
might be going on so it's important to
point that out and to acknowledge that
yeah what that suggests to me is that
they're probably or there there's a
pretty good chance that there's a real
effect but that the current research
might overestimate the magnitude of the
effect I think that's a very plausible a
very likely uh way to describe it yeah I
think and you could just you could say
that about many things you know I I
think that's the case of just like
research yeah yeah because generally
nulls are less likely to get published
yeah so usually the flashy findings from
people who it's like their pet theory
that come out early the effect sizes are
big they come back down to earth they
settle sometimes at zero sometimes above
zero but smaller than the initial
estimates so yeah I think it'll probably
settle above zero for most of these
outcomes but like most things smaller
than the initial biggest estimates of
effect size but I do want to address the
the heterogeneity point there are two
things I want to mention here uh first
of all intervention quality can vary
dramatically obviously just like
anything else like the metaphor that
I've used like if you ask if mindfulness
works that it's kind of to me like
asking if teaching works or if coaching
works yeah like yeah good teachers are
are excellent and really shitty teachers
the effect size there isn't going to be
as big right like yeah some people
aren't as good at coaching at teaching
some people aren't as good at designing
or implementing mindfulness
interventions and and frankly some
people aren't really all that about
receiving mindfulness interventions
right like there are many studies that
happen on college campuses kids need
extra credit and it's like here listen
to this for 15 minutes and then take
this little quiz you know I'm sure there
are some people who are just like yeah
the headphones are on but like am I
really focusing on my breathing am I
really blocking out the fact that I have
a date tonight yeah you're not really
doing mindfulness you're you're doing a
bit of mental math to see the extent to
which the Five Points of extra credit
you're about to get will uh whether
that's going to bump you up from a c to
a b exactly yeah so like mindfulness
absolutely depends on Intervention
quality and also just in individual's
receptiveness to doing mindfulness like
uh it I do wonder how you force someone
to accept and participate in in like
really engage with a mindfulness audio
tape for example
um another thing that that could
contribute to the heterogeneity and this
is also a really important point is that
uh there's a great review paper I'll put
a figure up here indicating that
mindfulness probably falls on like an
inverted U-shaped curve where having a
deficiency of mindfulness processes is
probably not ideal for well-being uh but
also having an excess of mindfulness
processes also is probably not ideal for
well-being and you kind of want to be in
the middle there I see you're you're
smiling and I have no idea why when I
see excess of mindfulness I just think
about the people who do psychedelics for
the first time and just lose their
[ __ ] mind yeah never to be retrieved
because it does I mean sometimes they
they just spiral in bizarre directions
but it does seem like you know the the
first time they experience like ego
death and get a different and like maybe
broader perspective on things uh
they just like get in their own head to
a dangerous extent and it just like
ruins their life no no there there are
definitely people who have like a
psychic psychedelic experience and then
just turn their life upside down and
it's like
I wish you would have thought about that
a little bit more beforehand yeah in
particularly Ayahuasca like I've I've
never done any psychedelics myself but
like I'd be open to trying them but like
not Ayahuasca like from talking to
people who've done psychedelics like
seems like most people generally have
like pretty good experiences with like
LSD and mushrooms but
it seems like about a a third of the
white guys who go down to Latin America
and do Ayahuasca for the first time just
go insane uh
and I don't want to roll those dice it's
it seems like a see what one it just
seems like a bad time like I've never
heard an Ayahuasca experience that
sounds fun uh and yeah like it it seems
uh very risky for for a lot of people
yeah I don't know much about it
um but yeah so when we talk about this
heterogeneity and effect size you know
the reality is that we not not I will
never do marijuana though correct just
to be clear for the purpose of the
podcast psychedelics as we all know gets
you closer to God this is as always a
Christian Family Values podcast yeah uh
not marijuana though that's no that's
the bad stuff right so
because of this kind of inverted
U-shaped curve we should expect that for
some people mindfulness is a really
positive intervention but for others it
could actually be contraindicated right
and so when I talked about mindfulness
processes and whether you have a
deficiency or an excess or kind of in
that optimal middle Zone uh for example
one process brought up in this paper and
I'll put this on the screen as well is
self-observation so if you're someone
who has really low self-awareness at
Baseline uh you know you have a
deficiency of this mindfulness process a
mindfulness intervention might be quite
helpful but if you're someone who is
kind of like you know
constantly observing yourself with a
high level of anxiety or depressive
symptoms or a high level even of like
dissociation the last thing you need is
like hey let's do a really deep
reflective mindfulness exercise and just
ruminate on this even more you know
that's like a pretty common symptom of a
lot of like eating disorders too right
um I I yeah I I think uh or is that like
a different type of self-observation I I
think um what you would probably want to
do I mean not this is not medical advice
but I would assume like you know we
talked about mindfulness for eating
behaviors I think usually the object of
observation there would be the food the
experience of eating it would be mindful
eating not let's do a lot of deep
contemplation about your body yeah right
so yeah it's kind of just on where the
mindfulness Focus would be but that is a
situation where I would I would suggest
or anticipate that one version of
mindfulness focusing on mindful eating
could be quite helpful in that scenario
but a very body focused reflective kind
of mindfulness exercise could backfire
in that situation
um another one that comes up here is uh
um exposure right so um there are some
instances where people have really high
experiential avoidance and in many types
of therapy they might actually walk you
through some kind of visualization
exercise almost as a form of like
exposure therapy to start building up
some degree of comfort level within a
safe setting you know with a medical
professional
um but of course uh if you are you know
have a ton of anxiety about a certain
thing and and just like it's a really
really adverse thing when you when you
start to think about it the last thing
you would want to do is some kind of
unguided kind of self-directed exposure
therapy where you're putting yourself
into this like catastrophically uh
deleterious psychological State over and
over and over like that's the type of
thing where if you had some kind of
phobia or or some kind of exposure
related thing like that you know a
self-guided mindfulness approach would
not be ideal you'd want to seek out
probably probably some type of
therapeutic uh intervention that's
Guided by a medical professional yeah
but those are just a couple examples in
which you know there are some cases
where being low on that mindfulness
curve you know doing a mindfulness-based
intervention could bump you up into that
optimal range and it'd be a very
positive thing but if you're already
starting with an excess of some of these
mindfulness processes doing more
mindfulness would either be unhelpful or
even in some cases could backfire a
little bit uh and so I think
when we think about the heterogeneity
that we see in this research of course
we should think about the kind of
standard research design and statistical
Concepts but we should also think about
this as a pretty targeted intervention
that that isn't really the right
intervention for all people in all
situations uh and then finally
if you've heard all this and you're
interested in maybe giving it a shot you
want to get started and try some
different types of mindfulness based
interventions or meditation
interventions uh a good question is how
to get started I think it's probably
best in my opinion to start with guided
meditation sessions to kind of show you
the ropes because a lot of times people
just sit there for 10 minutes and say
did I do it right and it's like I don't
know so yeah a guided meditation can be
really helpful and there's a variety of
free and paid apps that have those uh in
addition to websites as well if you're
specifically interested in mindful
eating like I said that paper by Nelson
gives a great description of how to
approach it and how to actually apply it
so I'll link that in the show notes and
then finally
um these mindfulness practices are kind
of an offshoot from Buddhism
um and which of course Buddhism takes a
lot of different forms but if you want
to explore some of the basic Buddhist
foundations in a totally
non-non-religious secular way
I actually think that can be helpful in
some cases like so because I try to do
some mindfulness stuff actually several
years ago before I'd ever thought about
Buddhism and one of the things I
struggled with was it was like okay now
contemplate and I was like
contemplate what and it made a lot more
sense to me when I started to understand
where some of this mindfulness
meditation came from when I learned some
of just the basic kind of foundational
Concepts uh within Buddhism things like
non-self things like aimlessness things
like impermanence some of these basic
foundational ideas it made it a lot
easier to understand oh I I understand
why I'm trying to get away from
ruminating on the past being anxious
about the future getting into the
present moment and kind of experiencing
the present moment in a non-judgmental
way like getting some of those
foundations was a very clarifying
experience for me that made it easier
for me to do
mindfulness interventions that really
had nothing to do with Buddhism so if
you're interested in getting some of
that foundational information I do
recommend Buddhism guide which is a
podcast by Karma yeshi RAB gay it's on
Spotify uh very very good very uh very
approachable very accessible and then
there's just a variety of books by
ticknot Han that I think are excellent
so in conclusion
uh mindfulness is not for everyone uh
like I said there is that kind of
inverted U-shaped curve
um it's not the perfect thing for all
people for all outcomes but there are
evidence-based applications when it
comes to recovery from mental fatigue
sleep enhancement eating Behavior
Improvement pain management and I think
the easiest way to dive in is to find a
nice app or a nice website that has some
some guided mindfulness exercises to
kind of show you the ropes and just to
be clear you don't have to switch
religions to get into this stuff you
don't have to commit to any kind of
dogmatic beliefs or Embrace any
metaphysical Concepts in order to
participate I think a lot of people
would be surprised to see how
approachable these things are and they
can be as simple as just saying hey take
a few deep breaths calm down and just
give your mind permission to rest uh and
after you do that a few times it becomes
really alarming you start to realize
like I don't think my brain was resting
for like 12 years until I gave this a
shot so uh not for everybody but but you
know it's it can be a helpful thing for
for the outcomes that I mentioned